that's the i do
my maybes as well
so this is my mind maybe i like that my
maybe thank you
so maybe yeah that should be the name of
your next special
my maybe i've never had a special
is that because you don't feel special
oh that could be
i think that that was oh [ __ ] with you
just oh [ __ ] what he just said kind of
real huh really cut into it
oh [ __ ] that hurt
oh you're right are you doing a
monologue
i'm trying to stand
sometimes i'll no just wait
sometimes i stand to see if a monologue
will happen
okay right so let's see if let me stand
still let's do it again you wanna go
back to one yeah
um what do you want me to take it from
from well how did you lead me into it do
you remember is that because you don't
feel special
whoa
oh man so oh [ __ ]
i think you hit a court there man yeah
um
so
what are you doing dude don't [ __ ]
move when i'm doing a monologue oh wow
very christian bale i'm doing christian
video
huh
you know what i'll hang out with you i'm
not working with you anymore you didn't
say that something like that something
like this yeah yeah all right i'm stan
i'm sitting down back down now
okay what was the problem there though
you're a cut off
standing up he's trying to give me
another lead please
is that because you don't feel special
growing up i um glad you said that
because growing up
my parents didn't speak english and they
never um
talked to me about anything i was abused
and
i was
someone touched my pp as a kid and stuff
and um
yeah
i grew up feeling that i was like a
piece of [ __ ] and not special and so i
think that
a lot of people asking me to do a
special um i think it's fear not fear i
think it's a reflection on how i
actually feel about myself
cut
[Music]
that was perfect now listen on this next
take
that was perfect again yeah
all right yeah okay we got to that
yeah
are you the director here huh are you
the director i know i ended that whole
thing i'm just oh i'm just me again
sorry i'm sorry oh we're just moving on
i thought we're just gonna move on oh i
thought we were in the scene okay my bad
right so that was pretty good guys or no
that's good that's pretty good not great
though not great oh [ __ ] but good enough
yeah you're right i don't feel special i
think
also i have a
can i ask you a question i hate to ask
this but um
and i know i've been doing comedy for so
long bill
and i need advice
because i can never tell if you're being
so i'm being [ __ ] dead serious right
now okay i need help